you're not new in this industry at all
but what's been happening with a star is
born the past couple of weeks it's just
on another level so I'm just curious how
you're processing this whirlwind of
praise and attention
yeah I'm 100% taking it one moment at a
time I'm like I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to think ahead I'm not trying to
think about what happened yesterday like
I'm just like all right we're here today
and it's just awesome to celebrate a
piece of art and and a body of work that
we're all proud of and that we care
about that that now seems to resonate
with people in the way that it does with
us curious about going into the audition
for a role like this do you walk in that
door saying to yourself if I get this
I'm gonna start opposite Lady Gaga or do
you have to get that out of your head
completely I mean yeah I mean yeah for
sure like I'm like wow the potential of
what this can be is incredible but but
once you get there and you're in the
midst of it and we're doing the reading
you know I'm at did three tapes before I
had to read with the cast in in a
reading and I can't remember I don't
even was at some room in the conference
room and and and you get in there and
you're just like alright you know we're
all just people and we're all trying to
make something good and just be your
best you and your best is going to speak
for itself you know you can't give
anything but what you got speaking of
being your best you I think one of the
biggest takeaways for me from this movie
was I just walked out thinking about
self-doubt and a support system more
than anything and I loved seeing a movie
like this that inspires me to think back
and make a list of all the people that
really made a big difference in my
career so I'm wondering who is that
person for you and is there anyone out
there that really made a difference in
your life that maybe you haven't
expressed that to yet yeah I mean I
don't know if there's someone I haven't
expressed it to yet you know cuz I and
if there is I'm truly sorry because I
really do my best to tell people who
have made an impact on my life how how
amazing they are and
much I thank them for everything they've
done but and in particular of this one
teacher who is the sole reason why I'm
you know I'm it's not the only reason
why but she definitely is the core to
this to this to this to me being an
actor and me getting into this and and
she know she she paid for my
applications to the one school I applied
for she helped me write the essays she
she she got me a full you know she gave
my name so I get into the school I can't
afford that she gave my name to a
Scholarship Foundation and they met me
and she told them you gotta meet this
cake cuz you know I believe he's special
and she believed in me which in turn you
know which in turn you know they took
her word for it met me heard my story
and then called me two days later after
those schools calling me for a loan that
I completely can't afford they like
we're gonna give you a full ride to
school and immediately my life has
changed because this one person just
didn't give up on me so you know assists
it's a blessing you know so these
moments you know I don't take the for
granted